join us join us mightiest heroes not
today sir are you making your voice
deeper you know
on April 27 summer begins he's mocking
me he's trying to copy me confident he
wore a smash-and-grab heist film you
know it's Thanos his intent on
collecting the Infinity stones and it's
gonna move quickly to do it because he
knows when word gets out that he's
trying to collect the Infinity stones
that the forces of the universe are
going to line up against him so he's got
a ticking clock and that that's kind of
the essence of the film it's a very
simple plot after Avengers three and
four Marvel Studios will begin a new
phase in its universe do you feel like
you as directors of some of the biggest
movies of the studio have reached the
end of a cycle - I mean look we love
working with Marvel we love it yeah we
didn't we prioritize the quality of our
experience with the quality of the work
and and Marvel it's always been both
areas have been of the highest he could
possibly want to desire so we've had an
amazing experience working with them you
know they've been so focused on these
movies though that we haven't been
thinking beyond them we'll say though
that that Fox deal goes through with
Disney there's a lot a lot more
characters to work with all this and be
interesting to do something like Secret
Wars wait a minute Secret Wars what did
he just say look at the face on his
brother when he says that word like he's
just smiling like oh yeah something's
coming down the pipeline I will address
the Disney Foxx deal but there's so much
New Avengers stuff to break down love
the t's for forces of the universe so
that's where he's talking about
Celestials he's talking about the elders
of the universe the larger cosmic
entities moving against Thanos so I'll
address all those people in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because we've mostly
been focusing on the Avengers in the
guardians teaming up to fight Thanos so
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway -
recently the trades reported that Fox
had been talking to their people
about the Disney deal like hey you're
not gonna lose your jobs this is what's
gonna happen conservative estimate they
said the dust is gonna settle on
everything
in Kevin Feige we'll get to do whatever
he wants to with those Fox characters at
the end of next summer 2019 that doesn't
confirm that they're gonna add any
post-credit scenes or anything like that
to Avengers 4 they could work in verbal
references they could do things at the
last minute if they know that the deal
is going to close but they can't really
cross those characters over unless Kevin
Feige makes an arrangement with Fox
before the deal closes because until the
deal closes all of the power in making
that decision where those characters
appear still rests with the Fox people
it doesn't really revert to Disney until
ink is dry on paper in what the Fox
people are telling their employees is
that that's going to be done at the end
of the summer 2019 that could happen
faster it could happen later but they
also reveal some details about the
technicalities they said that the Fox
people are basically gonna stay in their
studio space right now Disney's gonna
lease that for the next seven years but
for the most part it's about what you'd
expect like they'll just get access to
that IP so whatever their plans are for
Avengers five they can totally do secret
Wars which is why you know you see one
of the Russos here sort of smiling into
camera as the other ones like yeah you
know Secret Wars now I think that kind
of crossover is the easiest prediction
to make everybody's been thinking about
that but the Russos themselves are done
with Avengers films after infinity war
they're not totally done with Marvel but
it does sound like they're gonna go and
do something else for a couple years
before they come back so whoever does
the next Avengers film will be somebody
else but talking about the Celestials
they're the big cosmic people in the
Marvel Universe if they were a big part
of the comic book Infinity Gauntlet
story what's going on with them in the
movie universe but it just sounds like
from the way they talked about it they
didn't actually write the Celestials as
characters into the movie they might get
referenced Peter quill referenced
eternity which is probably the biggest
concept that Marvel has ever teased next
to the multiverse which opens a whole
host of possibilities
[Music]
but when they say that the forces of the
universe will find out what the Annis is
doing and move to stop him they're also
talking about the Watchers the most
powerful cosmic beings that we've met so
far I don't really include Dormammu in
that because he's not from our universe
he's from the Dark Dimension but I think
they're also teasing a lot of stuff
that'll appear during Avengers 4 that
we'll see for the first time during the
Captain Marvel movie like we've never
met the Skrulls
there's whole areas of the universe that
we never traveled to before Thor
Ragnarok was the good example of that
like literally the end of the universe
where all the trash gets dumped so if
during this guardians of the galaxy
sequence you see them bouncing through
all these different space portals to go
to different areas in the universe James
Gunn has teased that we're gonna meet a
lot of those people in the next 10 years
in the movies they'll be like a bunch of
new cosmic movies that they haven't
really talked about yet because I think
it's still in the early planning stage
because I do think we're gonna meet more
Celestials we'll probably get more into
like the grand concepts seriously think
about it this way if James Gunn did a
talking planet then think about what
he's going to do when they get really
crazy in phase 4 and whatever phase 5 is
going to be biggest prediction for those
new big space based movies is that they
eventually work up to an ultimate
team-up movie which you know could
either include Captain Marvel or some of
the other new characters if you're not
familiar with that title Ultimates is
like a comic book line that Marvel did
the ultimate universe but it's also the
name of a team-up that Black Panther
funds that mostly deals with big cosmic
concepts whereas like the Avengers deal
with more identifiable villains like
they fight Thanos they fight the other
like physical beings The Ultimates deal
with problems like Galactus the super
flow if you're not familiar with the
super flow is that's sort of like this
space outside of reality where cosmic
concepts communicate with each other do
not be surprised in the next 10 years if
you see them introduced blue Marvel
spectrum America Chavez America Chavez
is probably a little bit easier to do
blue marble but I wouldn't be surprised
if they use Captain Marvel is sort of
the go-between character that does space
based movies sometimes and does
earth-based movies sometimes because
they're always going to be the Avengers
cross
verse those will still be relatively
earth-based they'll go into outer space
when they cycle the Guardians roster
they'll still be a relatively space
based movie so they're just a couple
easy crossover characters that have one
foot in both of those areas that you
could serve as like a point of
connective tissue between whatever this
new cosmic universe is gonna be like the
traditional Marvel Universe like you see
in spider-man movies I know everybody's
pushing for Galactus will know
something's up if the Marvel people like
Kevin Feige James Gunn come to comic-con
2019 for their Marvel panel to announce
whatever is happening next and they're
wearing x-men t-shirts they'll be the
ultimate teaser they wouldn't even need
to tell you what they're doing just show
up wearing x-men paraphernalia and
that'll let you know oh we're getting
ready for a crossover there was a lot of
other Hawkeye that they talked about a
lot of like the missing characters
secret characters like Peter Dinklage so
I'll do a video for that soon leave all
your infinity war video requests in the
comments below and I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
but click here to watch Stannis use the
Infinity Gauntlet and click here for
that funny behind-the-scenes video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight